قبيله فصل الشتاء البارده في اوروبا
الشرقيه طرف الصراع في اوكرانيا يحاولان
المضي قدما في استراتيجيه مختلفه تماما
لحسم المعركه قبل التوجه نحو التفاوض
روسيا وتفاديا لمواجهه جينيرال الثلج
والطين تواصل استخدام الجو واستهداف البنا
التحتيه للطاقه الاوكرانيه
اوقفت الامدادات لما يصل الى 40% من
السكان الاوكرانيين انقطاعات قد تستمر
لعده ساعات مع درجات حراره اكثر بروده ما
يضع ضغطا اضافيا على شبكه الطاقه خطوه
موسكو تاتي للضغط على الجانب الاوكراني
وتحقيق مكاسب القصوى قبل الجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات وفق خبراء
لكن في المقابل موسكو اقدمت على الانسحاب
من مناطق اوكرانيه مختلفه قبيل فصل الشتاء
خاصه في خرصا
فاستطيعوا ودرجات الحراره المنخفضه جدا قد
تجعل الجيش الروسي يعاني لمواصله القتال
والحفاظ على المناطق التي يسيطر عليها وقد
تكون التكلفه باهضه عده عتادا صعوبه
يواجهها الجيش الاوكراني ايضا الذي لن
يكون حاله افضل في مناخ صعب وقاص رغم انه
حقق بعض النتائج في مناطق مختلفه فهو
بحاجه الى امدادات عسكريه غربيه
ومقاتلات اف 15 مطالب قد لم تلقى اذان
صاريه من الغرب الذي لا يود الصدام اكثر
مع روسيا فصل قد يكون بدايه للوصول الى حل
لحرب انطلقت قبل تسعه اشهر خلال الوجداني
العربيه